I hope you had a chance to look over the study on keto and breast cancer metastasis.
Does this look legit and we should take this and does this and we should we take this to heart
those of us doing keto. So this person emailed me a study on ketogenic diets, possibly being
harmful to those with breast cancer and could possibly cause metastasis to breast cancer patients.
And is this legitimate? Yeah, I do think it's legitimate, but I would
refus that to say that I am said from the very beginning of time that I am starting to work with
cancer patients back in the late 90s, is that every cancer is different to say, you know, that's
why I have always been against these, you know, books that come out like SIGFREED's book that
said every single cancer patient should be doing a ketogenic diet. No, they shouldn't, you know,
or every, you know, or Chris's works work that every cancer patient should be vegan and be doing
juicing or, you know, a person that everybody should be doing 12, 13 glasses of juice, carrot,
apple juice on a daily basis. That's, I just told, I just personally disagree with that. I think
everybody is unique. And the idea that cancer can feed off of certain metabolic pathways is
obviously evident, you know, how come some people do a ketogenic diet and it seems to put a
halt on the other cancer and some people do a ketogenic diet and you know, the cancer continues
to grow because everybody is different and cancer is always looking for a pathway in order to feed
itself. So many times you have to change up when we first initially do a cheek swab testing on
somebody and let's say it's just fed through glycolysis and maybe dairy and we take you off of
those things on a low sugar diet and low dairy, no dairy or low dairy and a year later it changes
and we have to change the diet because it's found a new fuel source, not always, but that does
exist and it's a possibility. So we just have to be aware of that. So I would agree that I think
that there's cancers that can be fed on a ketogenic diet. Well, what's a ketogenic diet? Well, you're
eating a lot of animal meat and which you're going to get a high level of glutamine which glutamine
can be a fuel source for cancer, glutamine and methionine. Many ketogenic diets also are high in
dairy. So this study didn't separate that out because there's a lot of people on a ketogenic diet
that are eating meat and dairy, I mean, that's their biggest thing is they're eating meat, fat, and dairy
a carnivore diet is eliminating the dairy part, but a ketogenic diet certainly isn't. So dairy is
going to be a driver of most everybody's cancer because of the growth hormones in it. So, you know,
again, I mean, I am put very new people on a ketogenic diet or they're on it for a short period of
time and most people that are on a ketogenic diet as far as our patients are brain cancer patients.
So I would agree that this study could show that, but to be honest, you could also probably show a
study putting them on the opposite of a ketogenic and juicy diet and they're and they're and it can
cause bets in some breast cancer patients or colon cancer patients or bladder cancer patients
doesn't make any difference. So because there's a there's a percentage of people in every group,
every cancer group that, you know, their cancer is going to be fed mainly off of glutamines.
A ketogenic diet certainly would be not recommended and there's other people in that group that their
cancer may be fed mainly directly through glycolysis and therefore, you know, something like a juicy
diet would not be recommended. So you have to understand the changing facet of, you know,
cancer always try to find a fuel source.